Congress plans to vote later today on a
bipartisan compromise budget bill that
will prevent another partial government
shutdown
White House officials believe President
Trump will sign it even though it
doesn't give him the money to build a
border wall the president indicated
yesterday he will find another way to
build it as we review the new proposal
from Congress I can promise you this
I will never waver from my sacred duty
to defend this nation and its people we
will get the job done the wall is very
very on its way Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill Hill rather where the final
plan was revealed overnight Nancy good
morning to you good morning and that
final plan is expected to get
overwhelming support when it goes up for
a vote in the House and Senate today no
one wants to see another shutdown and
they want to send a powerful message to
the president that he should sign this
bill even if it doesn't contain
everything that he wanted the bill does
give the Department of Homeland Security
roughly 25 billion dollars for border
security funding in 2019 that's a modest
increase from 2018 included is nearly
one point four billion dollars for
physical barriers fifty-five new miles
of fencing along the border now that
fence which some Republicans are calling
a wall will be steel packed with
concrete 30 feet tall in some areas 18
feet tall in others and one thing that
won't be in the bill is a measure that
was proposed by Democrats at the last
minute to provide back pay to federal
contractors affected by the government
shutdown the White House signaling that
the president will sign the bill and he
has said repeatedly Norah that he'll
find the rest of the money he wanted
somewhere else all right Nancy looks
like a beautiful morning there in
Washington thank you